[Music]
that's all i'm gonna do
tokyo olympics starting later this month
about 10 days and counting or bringing
back memories of the first time
japan hosted the summer games back in
1964
this was an opportunity for a defeated
and devastated country
to show that it had transformed itself
into a modern nation
unlike today when some officials say the
game should be canceled
due to covid every japanese citizen
stood behind the massive effort to
welcome the world to tokyo
lucy kraft met some of those people who
will who will be watching she's trying
to say
the latest olympics and thinking of what
they did 57 years ago
[Music]
emperor hirohito and jesse owens watch
as
bob hayes adds his name to the honor
roll of champions
from the emperor on down every japanese
seemed to be on the same team
back in 1964 pumped about welcoming
visitors
and determined to pull off a perfect
olympics just 19 years
after japan's defeat in world war ii
among them was a painfully shy teenaged
factory worker
named mitsuru suzuki now 76
suzuki and his wife sachiko run a noodle
joint in downtown tokyo
pride of place belongs to his old jersey
from one of the most exciting moments in
his life
running in the 1964 tokyo olympic torch
relay
suddenly people at the factory knew my
name i became their little hero
back then the entire country was on an
adrenaline rush
said author roy tomizawa this is a
komazawa olympic park
and it was the site of field hockey
tomizawa a self-described olympics nerd
who's written a book on the first tokyo
olympics
argues 1964 was the greatest year in
japanese history
i don't think i can imagine a time that
japan was more aligned in its mission
to one get the country back on its feet
and two make sure that the 1964 tokyo
olympics was a fantastic show
that impressed the heck out of the rest
of the world as host nation for the
first games to be held in asia
the japanese have gone all out to
provide the best facilities possible
instead of a devastated country that
made cheap toys
japan was shockingly hyper modern with
brand new super highways and the world's
fastest train
its famous bullet train people were
really
surprised at the quality of the
technology
the stunning success of 1964 looms large
over this summer's olympics
observers say it helps explain why japan
is so determined to push ahead with the
games
despite widespread public opposition
amid the global pandemic
still grappling with the 2011 quake
tsunami and nuclear catastrophe
and prolonged economic malaise japan had
sought another
olympics-inspired do-over noodle shop
owner suzuki said the 1964 olympics
changed his life
giving him and other young japanese a
new sense of confidence and optimism
sentiments he says are missing today
this year things are totally different
in 1964
everyone was excited about the olympics
now people aren't so sure we should have
an olympics at all
this time the olympics has divided the
country instead of uniting it
and recapturing that old olympics magic
has
never seemed more elusive for cbs this
morning
lucy craft tokyo yeah
what a difference do you remember this i
do remember it
because there were some there were some
very big olympic stars from the us
at that time and i was sort of when i
first was coming conscious of what the
olympics were yeah but what's so
interesting this time is i mean the
vaccination rate in japan is
startlingly low and and given how much
faith and hope they had in this olympics
you would have thought they would have
prepared more
in that regard i'm actually a little
worried about the olympics but i also
feel for the athletes who have been
training training training
yeah it's heartbreaking for them yeah
years of work
and they miss this moment it's hard to
know what the right thing to do is we
want things to go back to normal we want
our athletes to be celebrated but they
need to be safe too
exactly